So we know from before that applications
compete for bandwidth. Consider a Voice over
IP application and a file transfer application
that want to share a common network link.
In this case, we'd like the audio
packets to receive priority over the file transfer
packets. Since the user's experience can be
significantly degraded by lost or delayed audio packets.
In this case, we want to mark the audio packets as they arrive at the router,
so that they receive a higher priority. Then
the file transfer packets. You might imagine implementing
this with priority queues where the void packets
were put in one queue and the file
transfer packets are put in a separate queue
that is served less often than a high
priority queue. An alternative is to allocate
fixed ban width per application, but the problem
with this alternative. Is that it can result
in inefficiency if one of the flows doesn't
fully utilize its fixed allocation. So the
idea, in addition to marking and policing, is
to apply scheduling. One way of applying scheduling
is to use what's called weighted fair queuing,
whereby the queue with the green packets is
served more often than the queue with the
red packets. Another alternative is to use admission
control, whereby an application declares its needs in advance,
and the network may block the application's traffic
if the application can't satisfy the needs. A busy
signal on a telephone network is an example
of admission control. But can you imagine how annoying
it would be if you attempted to load a web page
and were blocked. This blocking or the user experience that results
from it, is a negative consequence of admission control and is
one of the reasons it's not commonly applied for internet applications.